*intense music* THIS IS IT.
This is FINALLY it. This is it AGAIN.
This is the moment that you've all been waiting for.
𝐂 𝐋 𝐎 𝐀 𝐊
has officially LAUNCHED, as of R I G H T  N O W.
Go to cloakbrand.com and you can find all of our previous items
BACK IN STOCK
B A B E H
And, in addition to that, you've got two brand spankin' new items:
THIS BEANIE,
and the infamous quarter zip, available in two luscious colors.
The comfort!
The fit!
The NWEUPS ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)-
Hey guys, my name is Markiplier, and today marks the official launch of cloakbrand.com
And Cloak in general.
This is it, like, this IS the day.
Last time, if there's anybody that's confused,
last time we were talking about the brand at first.
We did a pre-sale, we opened up the website, but now is when things actually get moving.
And it's exciting!
It really is. It's exciting to see because this is the day
when all of the work that we've done for the past two years finally hits the ground, and it's running.
Everybody that preordered their stuff will be getting their, like, getting their new clothes as early as next week.
And if you go to the website right now, cloakbrand.com, you can start ordering everything that you didn't get a chance to before.
Everything sold out in like 2 days last time.
And that blew us away. We had no idea that things were going to be like that,
we thought it was going to be a slower burn towards the launch day, which is today.
But you guys didn't.
Cuz you guys always push past what we expect you to do.
You guys always exceed everything that we could possibly hope for.
You guys are so unbelievably supportive of what we do,
and that means the world to us.
Honestly, truly, that means the world to us.
We can't thank you enough for supporting this new venture of ours.
And-And we know this may seem out of our element for you guys,
but this is something that we've been passionate about.
For years.
Something we've wanted, something we've assembled a great team of people for.
And... you guys supported it.
And I can't say how much that means to us.
I cannot overstate...
how important that belief is to us.
Because we never want to betray that trust that you guys put in us,
and we always wanna make stuff for you that we're proud to make.
And that is the whole point of Cloak. We wanted to make stuff that we would wanna wear.
We wanna make stuff that we're proud to show off.
We wanna make stuff that we're proud to make for you.
And that's what we've done.
And when people first start getting their things next week, I think you guys are going to be blown away.
I cannot wait for you to see it.
It is something... that we never thought we'd be able to do, and yet, we've done it.
And it's only because of you guys.
So thank you so much. I've got nothing else special to say,
oh, I guess I do. We have new beanies in stock,
if you go to cloakbrand.com with the launch, we've got new items,
uh..
every time that we wanna get, like, a restock, we wanna try to put new items out as often as we can.
Now, this may be, like, a couple items every quarter, every few months or so,
but we will do what we can, when we can. We've got a plan, and hopefully we can stick to it, but we've got a plan.
And in this part of the plan, we've got new beanies, available at cloakbrand.com, and new quarter zips.
So if you go to cloakbrand.com or click the link in the description below,
you can get this lovely, luscious, new cloak brand quarter zip.
And it's available in black as well, so it's available in gray and black.
And down the road, hopefully, we will be adding new items sooner than you guys expect,
so check in with all the social media channels for Cloak,
cloakbrand on instagram and twitter,
and just thank you...
Honestly, thank you so much for believing in us.
Thank you for believing in Cloak. Thank you for preordering, thank you for supporting us,
just thank you.
For being there when we needed you.
And for believing in what we believe in.
So thank you again,
and as always,
I will see you, in the next video.
BUH-BYE~ !!